And when I say,
"The good fortune of traveling to Iran."
Most people, let's say,
from the Western world would say
"How is that good fortune?"
and I would respond
"Well, if you wanna go to a culture..."
"and meet a people that are
hospitable, kind, open loving."
"Willing to give you everything."
That could be a meal, a place to stay.
Their thoughts, their time.
Then Iran is...
It's at the top.
It's one of those places in the world that
offers this warm, warm,
beautiful feeling of humanity.
Are there crazy, sh*tty people
in Iran too?
Of course, it's part of the human species.
But the vast majority
of the people I encountered
in your country of Iran
were amazing to me
and that's why I'm compelled
to make this video.
As we all know
Iran is all over the news right now.
It's all over Western media
and I don't want to get
political with this
because everyone else is.
But what I do wanna say
is the story that hasn't
been told so much.
Is the one of how Iranian people
are getting so marginalized right now
and their voices are not heard.
An example is sanctions.
So your country
has been squeezed very hard.
I was there in November
and I saw first hand, the impact
and the fallout from these sanctions
and how people's lives...
You know, in the middle class
were going to the lower class.
The lower class going to the streets.
People's food prices doubling.
I've received so many messages of people
not being able to afford medicine
for their families.
People dying because of this.
It's horrible
and that's not the story that's ever told.
So when I hear by my politicians
some of them saying, you know...
There's all this success with sanctions.
I question what does success mean?
What's the definition here?
Is the average person
getting screwed over?
Yes.
Is that successful? Not in my eyes.
Is the very wealthy
or top-level politicians...
Are they getting
screwed over by sanctions?
No.
They have plenty of money
for the rest of life.
So...
This drone strike happened the other day.
The downing of the drone
and now there's all this talk of war.
And I just... I've been thinking of
the Iranians I know.
The people I met.
The culture I was in
and I can't imagine
the stress this brings into your life
just knowing that there could be a war
and the stress of
financially getting pinched very hard.
Every American I know has no interest
in a war with Iran
and most people
if they knew what was happening
to the every day person in Iran
would have a lot of sympathy.
Because nobody deserves this.
Again, I'm gonna stay out of the politics.
There's bigger forces at play
that determine how world events happen.
I just wanna connect with you guys.
To let you know that you're not forgotten.
You're being thought of.
You will get through this.
Persian culture has gotten through
thousands of years of history.
[dogs barking]
There's some rogue dogs up there.
I gotta watch out. [chuckles]
I'm in Ukraine at the moment, in Kyiv.
But Persian culture has gotten through
thousands of years of history.
It will survive no matter what happens
and...
It's easy for me to say from the outside
but I just wanna let you know
that I am sending my thoughts
my love, my care...
and I know a lot of other people
feel the same way.
So that's about all I can do
at the moment.
I made videos of your country though too.
To show people
this beautiful part of your culture
that I'm talking about.
So with that
I wish you
to find some peace
as hard as that could be.
I can't imagine finding peace
in these circumstances but...
You know.
Tribing together
being there for one another
which you guys do really well
and knowing that there are
definitely better days ahead.
Okay.
Thanks for watching this.